for a long long time I didn't know
what's happening to the cows and the
chickens in the dairy and egg industry
so once I learned that they forcefully
impregnate the cows take their babies
away kill the balls exploit the mothers
for five years until they kill them run
up the male chicken so it's a lot of
injustice in there and once I learned
that I said okay I'm a hypocrite saying
that I love animals so consuming those
products so that's when I went vegan
organic these are videos from all over
the world even from Germany so regularly
we just let the people watch the
documentaries maybe for 30 seconds and
then we speak to them and we are some
questions to really think about it to
take a breath and maybe then talk
because these are very very hard
documentaries nobody wants to see it but
everyone wants to eat it you're not
gonna talk to somebody that never
thought about veganism and get them
vegan in a second you are just gonna
plant the seed and then the next person
or the next video they're gonna see is
gonna put their water on the seat and at
the end like the clouds are big is
embrace and we can be the last person to
talk to them and they convey or the
first view of killing of animals they're
gonna see in their life some people
might criticize that we are hiding
ourselves behind the mask but the
concept is first the meaning of V for
Vendetta which is about uncovering in
justices and fighting against it then
the second reason is when you go up to a
cube of truth
and watch the videos it's better for you
not to feel observed so when someone is
wearing the mask you don't feel like he
was judging me or he's gauging my facial
reactions so it makes it easier for
people to watch the video I just came
from there and I saw them all wearing
good wearing this mask is first of all
it is cool it is absolutely absolutely
attract my attention and also it's like
I had just just had a really nice
conversation with visited there and we
talked about is that's really human took
two cue animals and we shared our
different opinions I think it's good
yeah because normally you are working
your own life in your normal life you
don't think about these questions that
that's often that deep because eating
meat for us it's just to normal the
question I always ask at the beginning
is what do you think what are you your
feelings bother and then I always
precise that there's no wrong goal right
answer to that question and then I
always say okay so are you against
animal cruelty or do you not like that
people harm the animals and everybody
says no I don't like that and you say
but do you pay every day for the people
that you know and they'd be like yeah
that's the point
and I'm say lay out it's not about
judging people it's just about making
them realize and connect the fact that
they are paying for people to do what
they don't like to see the people do
tell us about the began violence against
animals and the Charter in the big
factories animal factories and we have a
small talk about to be vey again for one
week I'm not vegan now I'll try it for
one week and yeah my all wasn't enough
for me because I realized that good step
to do something in yourself but I want
to spread information to more people
nice way sometimes in my own environment
get kind of aggressive when you
and they get like that conscious here
it's a good way to get positive
information and to spread something
maybe contributing to our world
[Music]